soyons clairs nous ne nous associerons
pas à la France insoumise earn et ne
voteront pas ces motion de censure
[Applaudissements]
en les votant nous ferions tomber le
gouvernement mais cela aboutirait très
probablement un remplacer le
gouvernement Band 2 par un gouvernement
borne 3 et puis la semaine suivante par
un gouvernement borne 4 il y a là
au-delà d'un bref moment de satisfaction
d'opposant aucune utilité pour les
français bien sûr il y a sans doute sur
les bancs autour de vous madame la
Première ministre des candidats pour
vous remplacer je ne citerai pas les
noms il sera connaîtreont
mais si c'est pour faire la même
politique je n'en vois pas non plus
l'utilité pour les Français faudrait-il
faire tomber ce gouvernement parce qu'il
y aurait dans cette assemblée une autre
majorité possible à partir d'une autre
combinatoire politique comme le régime
des parties sont régalés avec des listes
sous la Quatrième République là encore
je n'en vois pas sauf si le
rapprochement des extrêmes à l'oeuvre
aujourd'hui va jusqu'à nous proposer
gouvernement en commun faudra-t-il alors
dissoudre cet assemblée pour en élire
une autre peut-être nous nous sommes
toujours prêts et retourner devant les
électeurs et toujours un moment de
bonheur mais à quatre mois quatre mois
après les élections après 8 semaines de
travail seulement de cet assemblée tout
cela ne nous paraît pas très sérieux
donner encore davantage de notre pays
l'image d'un bateau à la dérive n'est
pas dans l'intention du groupe les
républicains spéculer sur l'effondrement
du pays et le calcul de ceux qui aiment
le désordre jusque dans notre assemblée
mais ce n'est pas le nôtre
notre responsabilité pour la France
ajouter une instabilité politique et
paralysera le pays à l'inflation et à la
récession que les Français doivent
affronter si vos sous de censure madame
la Première ministre aujourd'hui
personne n'y croit donc vraiment pas
même ce qui les ont déposés mais soyons
clairs nous n'hésiterons pas à en
déposer une nous-même si les
circonstances l'exigent